alright my name is Courtney I'm a
professional BMX rider and I live in
Newton Abbot and our most of the
chairman of the decoy misfits BMX club
we've been working on funding the area
for five years been pretty long project
first off we had to get sort of
commission for the council it's go all
the route of insurance setting up a
proper love your went on medical courses
and various other things child
protection all thanks to Nikki sort of
God us fruit and then basically the ago
was secure lips at the end of five years
concrete skatepark could be you for BMX
and skate board and times it look like
it weren't going to happen at all but it
hasn't it sick really so I mean the
first step was we already added the dirt
jumps you can't see in the distance even
if about ten years first off we start by
getting them official again insurance
and setting up a club and actuate from
strength to strength fencing apart water
supply on roster inspections so without
with actually the first club in England
to be properly insured and set off of
the club the dirt jumping and the
natural EDD us on to the skatepark
really and just endless claim forms
meeting to the council local residents
noise testing you name it we've done it
and it's been pretty gnarly to be fair
and just thanks to Nikki really because
none of it would be possible about
you